Speaker 1: Ron DeSantis, his wife, Casey DeSantis,
is stealing Donald Trump's. They came to me with
tears in their eyes routine. So DeSantis is
already stealing the Joe Biden basement line
from Trump. Casey DeSantis is now stealing these
stories. Just as a reminder, Trump often tells
these stories. You know, they came to me, they
said, sir, and they were crying. These were big,
strong generals. And then they said, we don't
have any we don't have any bullets left. Obama
left the cupboards bare.
Speaker 2: OBAMA Now.
Speaker 1: And we always wonder, are these stories
real? I think the answer is probably not. Now,
Casey DeSantis is taking a shot
at one of these stories, like.
Speaker 3: I have the responsibility to come
out here and say this because I see him in front
of the cameras and I see him at home behind
the cameras and I see him with his kids six,
five and three. He never changes, He never
wavers. He never back down. He always,
always stands up for what's right. He does
not take the path of least resistance. He
doesn't cower. And it really is refreshing to see
that somebody is standing up for what is right,
standing up for the rights, liberties, livelihoods
and happiness of the people that he was voted to
represent. And that was true in spades when you
saw COVID. I can tell you stories of moms in the
midst of COVID single moms coming up to me with
tears in their eyes because they didn't know how
they were going to be able to put food on the
table for their kids. They didn't know whether
their children were going to be able to get an
education to live up to their God given potential.
Speaker 1: But they were crying. They would
go to bed. They weren't even going up to Ron
DeSantis. They were going up to Casey DeSantis
with tears in their eyes and crying. Listen. Is
it possible someone cried in Casey Desantis's
presence during COVID? I mean, sure. Do we
in general believe that everybody is constantly
crying in front of politicians who clearly don't
care about them? I struggle to believe that this
is a legitimate story. Let me know what you think.